تريد أن تلجأ الآن إلى خبير في هذا الأمر،
لدينا بوتش هندريك هنا معنا ولكن
لديك 30 عامًا من الخبرة
كغواص إنقاذ، وأنت أيضًا رئيس
ومؤسس أنظمة الإنقاذ وهي
شركة دولية للتدريب على الإنقاذ والاسترداد، هل تعلم؟  عندما
تبدأ بعملية إنقاذ مثل هذه،
أعتقد بنفس الطريقة التي
سيعمل بها خفر سواحل الولايات المتحدة والكنديون،
أول شيء هو اكتشاف ما
إذا كانت الوحدة الغاطسة تحتوي على
منارات قابلة للإطلاق، ومنارات للطوارئ، لذا
إذا فعلت ذلك، فمن المحتمل أن يتم
إطلاقها  منارة أو اثنتين إلى السطح
حتى يمكن تعقبهم،
ستنطلق إشارة من
خفر السواحل المظلم،
وسيتمكن الكنديون والبريطانيون من التقاطها ومن ثم
سيكونون قادرين على البدء في تتبع
المكان الذي قد تأتي منه
سننظر إلى ما حدث خلال الـ
48 ساعة الماضية للطقس، وما هي الظروف التي
ربما تغيرت والتي ليست طبيعية،
وما الذي كان سيحدث مع
التيارات في الأعماق وبين
القاع على ارتفاع 12000 قدم
ويمكن أن يكون السطح  تحدث وقد
تجاوزت فجأة قوة الوحدة، وستكون الغاطسة التي
تكون أسفلها هي أن
الوحدة الغاطسة المناسبة يجب أن تحتوي على
منارة أو اثنتين يمكن توصيلها
بها والتي يمكن أن ترسل
إشارة تحت الماء تخبر الناس
كيف  للعثور عليه،
لذا سأبحث عن أولئك الذين يراقبون
الطقس ويتتبعون ما
كان سيحدث إذا تم نقله من
الموقع، ومن المؤكد أن خفر السواحل
سيفعلون شيئًا مشابهًا جدًا
وسيأتون بمساعدتهم
إذا وجد المتتبعون الخاصون منارة تم
إطلاقها من هذا الرحمن فسوف
يرون أين كانت تتبع الطقس، ويضعون منارة
أخرى خاصة بهم في الماء
ويتتبعونها ويرون كيف ستسير الأمور
وأين ستكون الاحتمالات